so i think one really powerful way
to uh for me to understand aliveness
is to think about going to a darker
territory is to think about suicide and
i've known people in my life who suffer
from clinical depression yeah
and
you know whatever the chemistry is in
our brain
there is
a certain kind of
feeling that is to be depressed
where you look in the mirror
and ask do i
want to kill myself today
this is the question that kamu asks
this question this philosophical
question
and there is people
who
when they're depressed say
not only do they say i want to kill
myself or i don't they say it doesn't
matter
and that's chemistry that's whatever
that is that's chemistry in our mind
and then on the flip side of that for me
i've had some low points but i've very
been very fortunate to
not suffer from that kind of depression
i am the opposite which is
not only moments of peak performance in
athletics
or
great music or any of that
i'm just deeply joyful often by
mundane things like as you were saying
it i was drinking this thing and it's
cold and for some reason the coldness of
that was uh
like oh great like refrigeration i don't
know there was a joy in that like i
can't put it into words but i just felt
great and then just so many things you
look out in nature
there's a nice breeze and just like
it's amazing so that
that doesn't feel
like i'm embracing the absurd that seems
like i'm getting some nice like dopamine
hits
in whatever the chemistry is from just
the basics of life and that is the
source of aliveness however my brain is
built
it's gotten
a natural
sort of mechanism for
for aliveness
and so the one nice way to see the
absence of aliveness is to look at the
chemical the clinical depression
and so that camus doesn't seem to
contend with that at all in asking the
question of suicide because when you
look in the mirror and ask like if i ask
myself do i want to kill myself today i
ask that question in a different way
more like a stoic way often like
basically every day is you know what if
i die today it's more like contemplating
your mortality every single day
you know uh that
excites me
the possibility that this is my last day
that you know it just reminds me how
amazing life is and that's that's
chemistry i don't know what that is but
that's not that's certainly not
some kind of philosophical decision i
made
i am a little bit riding a wave of the
chemistry of the genetics i've been
given
of the dopamine so that that question of
suicide
by the way do you do you find that
formulation of the question of
existentialism
i know you didn't want to teach it
because obviously suicide is a very
difficult word especially for young
minds but do you think that's a useful
formulation of the question of
existentialism
like him saying this is the most
important question of suicide i think i
think there is something to it if if you
read the question as the question
what is it in virtue of which it ought
to be
desirable to conti to live the lives
that we're capable of of living
that's that's a deep question yeah
that's a question that gets focused
when someone asks themselves whether
they ought to continue to live that life
who
would the famous line nothing focuses
the mind more than one's impending
execution
i mean i think that's i think there's
something
important about that that recognizing
the riskiness and the vulnerability
of
one's existence is
super important and the idea and i think
that if we didn't have that
our lives
wouldn't be capable of being meaningful
if they weren't risky and vulnerable
there would be nothing to lose
and it's only because they're things to
lose that they can come to have the
significance that they do so yeah i
think
not against the idea that that's
a deep way of approaching the questions
at the core of of existentialism but as
you say i was worried for a while about
how i was gonna how i was gonna teach it
well i think there's a difference
between suicide and not living i
because suicide is an action
yeah so it feels like to me
uh like suicide doesn't make sense
because
you know imagine you're in like a hotel
and you're saying the room i'm in
but like there's other rooms so
like maybe explore those other rooms
maybe you'll find
meaning in those other rooms like
basically
embracing the fact that you don't know
everything
and there's uh you need time to explore
everything it's like
once you've explored everything then
maybe you can make a full decision but
it's um
unfair to make
a decision
it's i would say unethical
to make a decision until you've explored
all the rooms in the hotel yeah and this
gets focused in in the brothers
karamazov of course there's one brother
who
is really asking that question is asking
the question of suicide he's asking the
question whether
the world that we live in is a world
that's worth living in
and i think that characters as you say
very ill i mean that and and it's
possible
um
and often because as you say of you know
brain chemistry physiologies there's
certainly a physical ground to that to
that situation to that condition
um
but i think it is it is possible for
someone to be in that situation
i think that
ivan karamazov who's the who's the
character who's asking this question
is can you know maybe let's say
chemically depressed or something like
that but i think there's more to it too
and i think that dostoevsky's real view
is that the brain chemistry doesn't
exist on its own like the way we
interact with one another the way we
care about or isolate ourselves from
others the way we
care for the lives that we lead
affects the chemistry of our brain which
goes on and changes the mood that we're
in so i think dostoevsky
does think that
um
ivan's salvation if he's capable of
being saved
is going to come through the love of his
brother alyosha
you